joining me now is retired army
lieutenant colonel daniel davis he's now
a senior fellow at defense priorities
lieutenant colonel davis
um there are only a few people in the
media actually raising
any questions about the practical
reality here politico's defense reporter
recently asked on twitter
who are the ukrainian pilots
that will fly them do we know their
capabilities
i ask you do we know that answer tonight
yeah but we don't and there's there's so
many questions we don't know and and man
i i just
agreed with virtually everything you
just said you laid the situation out so
clearly uh but but i would just add on a
couple of issues which it really
highlights even more why this is not
such a good idea vladimir putin not just
might
view this in a negative way but he has
expressly said vladimir putin himself
that if any nation sends fighter jets
into the airspace of ukraine and attacks
and those jets attack uh russian
soldiers he'll consider that country to
be a participant in the war and will
react appropriately or properly and may
even attack that airfield i think that's
the reason why you saw poland when they
were talking about sending these things
over said okay how about we send them
over to ramstein air base in germany and
you guys can figure out how to get them
there because they don't want their
airfield attacked justifiably so because
anything that does that possibility of
triggering the article 5 and then now
allison you may have a war with the
united states and russia nato and russia
and there is nothing absolutely nothing
in in providing these migs that is worth
the possibility that the united states
could then be in war and now that
instead of just the tragedy in ukraine
that you described so well now that it
may be in warsaw or in in slovakia or
god forbid a nuclear extract in the
united states nothing is worth that now
there's actually an american who owns a
mig 19 or maybe 29 29 or 19. i think i
thought it was 29 maybe it's 19.
um here's what he told nbc news jared
isaac man a billionaire and an astronaut
may be the only individual to own a
mig-29 he said the russians could
eliminate the jets from the battlefield
in a single shot there are russian
fighters that could see those mig-29s
from three times farther away
again lieutenant colonel you're the
expert here um but that seems like a big
deal or am i wrong
that i mean that that's exactly right i
was even thinking on the practical even
if they came from ramstein you know that
russia's uh
anti-aircraft capability is going to be
watching all their radars are going to
be pointing there they're going to be
looking for it those things might get
shot down before they ever even land in
ukrainian airspace or on the on our
airfield as soon as they get in there
they will be a target and that's the
reason why you have this rather large
fleet of ukrainian fighters right now
that aren't getting in the air five to
ten per day as you just mentioned there
a second ago because they know they
can't get them up so what is 20 more
aircraft that you can't fly how's that
going to help anybody so you have this
huge risk that it could expand the war
and then on the other side there's very
little possible tactical upside and it's
just not a good idea it's not smart and
we shouldn't do it well someone like a
mitt romney perhaps or mike mccall might
say well you're playing into putin's
hands
by analyzing it this way you're allowing
him to call every tune he bluffs he puts
his chest out and america withers on the
world scene and that just emboldens the
chinese to do what the chinese are going
to do uh with taiwan how would you
respond to that yeah i i say you know
what this is actually looking at reality
but you can't make policies based on
what you wish was true based on what we
hoped would be the case we would like to
have ukraine have these jets and that
they make a difference the reality is is
you're talking from these experts
they're telling you it's not going to
make a difference and it is going to add
a risk this is i don't care anything
about what putin thinks or what he
threatens or anything else
if it doesn't have any if it's not based
on reality that's going to help the
united states i'm all about taking risks
and i did it in combat and i would
advocate the united states doing it if
it made sense and it had a good chance
of success this doesn't well also
we didn't even get to tonight whether it
actually enhances america's security
that's another i mean that kind of isn't
even discussed at all but lieutenant
colonel davis very important yeah a very
important conversation tonight actually
asking the questions many of which were
not asked the last time we got
going on a war in 2003 but we really
appreciate it thank you hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else